Kim K is retiring and I'm just going to
be an attorney reality TV may have made
Kim Kardashian a household name
I'm Kim Kardashian the princess is in
the building but she says she'd be
A-Okay if the camera stopped rolling I'm
really good focused on like Beauty
fragrance
skims law school mom that is more than
enough for me the kkw beauty founder
spoke at the time 100 Summit in New York
City on Tuesday and when she was asked
if she would ever consider a life
outside of the spotlight she said
absolutely I would be just as happy
being an attorney full-time and doing
that it gets overwhelming because
there's so much to be done and I just um
I would totally spend more time doing
that
cameras No cameras of course Kim's
journey to becoming a lawyer has been
well documented on the famous family's
reality show my goal would be in like 10
years to give up being Kim K and just
focus on this and be an attorney and
fight for so many deserving people Kim
has focused her attention on Criminal
Justice Reform in 2018 she met with then
president Donald Trump to advocate for
Alice Johnson a first-time non-violent
drug offender who was given a life
sentence without parole and Keeping Up
with the Kardashians cameras were
rolling as the reality star told Alice
she was getting out of prison the
president just called me and he told me
that
um that you are out he signed the papers
it's been released to the Press
everything do you think this will be
your life's most meaningful work ahead
I hope so
I hope so I always
joke with my mom who's my manager I say
Kim K is retiring and I'm just going to
be an attorney Kim yes
um so I was like so you can go help my
siblings are you
so you can still have like what about my
10 percent
um so I'm giving her the heads up it's
never a dull moment
and while Kim says her days on reality
TV are numbered fans can still look
forward to watching the Kardashian
Jenners on their Hulu series the
episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and I think that you
have a real insight not only you know
what you see in the press or whatever
but what's really happening behind the
scenes and I love that some of the
journeys that all of them are on and
there are different you know passions
and for example what Kim does with um
prison reform season three premieres May
25th and the trailer promises it won't
disappoint
listen everyone has their own truth of
how they think something happened
so
let's talk about it before you would see
little Snippets of something and now I
think the episodes are um you know
Fuller of content that shows the whole
story
[Music]
thank you